what happened with you guys you were in
some kind of plane crash or something
like that yeah yeah what and ever since
then you found god you have become very
religious is that true yes it is true no
i haven't played crazy
god's always there i've always been
there but uh but what is it like to be
in a plane crash this is what it's like
being a plane crash oh [ __ ] oh i don't
want to die this is right
big commercial plane yeah where were you
on your way
it was the us navy dc-9 the whole band
was on the plane
is that a private plane in other words
and why did you have a navy job because
you were touring and just like uso kind
of stuff for them right you were doing
something nice for free a charity kind
of thing yeah they tried to kill us you
played in a tent behind sandbags and
they they supply a plane for you because
after all you're a guest of the us
government yeah and then and then uh we
were coming back from bosnia and we went
to sicily and there was this insane
thunderstorm
and the guy flew right into it
and crash the plane basically flew into
the ground you mean you actually went
and i mean it hit the ground oh yeah the
wheels broke off the wheels wow popped
off there's holes in the wings
uh you know the funny the luggage
collapsed on us oh my god and then we're
going that's it we're dead we're going
to die what do you do and i'm i'm being
serious do you pee in your pants when
this is going on about 15 minutes after
that they well we waited on the runway
in this pouring rainstorm we went out
the little slide on the back of the
thing yeah we ran around the pacific
police
so the keystone cops of italy come over
right
load us into this load us into this
ambulance and take us to the hospital
which is
this is a scary thing most people would
would you know just freak out even
hearing about this
they announced i guess to you that oh my
god we're going to crash no they didn't
say anything you didn't say anything did
you tell you were going to crash did you
start to feel yourself descending
the guy tried to land three times he did
he kept circling no he went in went down
the plane was rocking like crazy they
went back up and went around again
because you got to keep trying over and
over again so the guy runs out of gas oh
my god
is that when you crashed when do you run
out of gas the plane hit the rumble
every time i land in a plane now
i keep waiting for that earth-shattering
boom so did you really think did you
enter into the picture well they're
alive no i meant during the you know
when when the plane is going down right
i didn't even think about that really
yeah well i always i was you know i
always kiss the little plane when i go
in and say please god don't let this
don't like that i already said you're
superstitious you're not a great fan
about flying and then and then uh but
at that point in time i was just
thinking [ __ ] [ __ ] right so
let me ask you this as it's going down
did you start to think what do you think
about your family did you think about it
life or anything what did you think
about and and did you reflection and you
really thought you were there with no
puking noise you can't see anything
right it's like it's just like dark dark
dark and all of a sudden bang
i'm gonna live differently if i survive
no we had to get we you know what we did
we went and uh we went and emptied a
couple of bottles of whiskey and got on
a plane five hours
really oh it's nuts man we were passing
out the valium like pez